[Música]
i
muy buenas tardes a todos a muchos de
los que están aquí me conocen por mucho
tiempo así que es un grato momento para
tener un espacio para conversar y yo les
voy a hablar de la innovación financiera
y principalmente basada en tecnologías
en el mercado de valores
por unos minutos nos vamos a concentrar
en una joven profesional que ha ahorrado
durante cinco años y que ahora a través
de sus soluciones financieras se le
permite acceder de una forma casi que
totalmente electrónica a través de su
móvil a sus cuentas de ahorros y a
conocer todo su historial financiero
esto lo hace con reconocimiento del iris
es una forma fácil que inclusive le
permite actualizar su perfil de
inversión y actualizar las nuevas
opciones de inversión que le ofrecen en
el mercado en unos pocos minutos ella
analiza la información toma una decisión
y ejecuta las órdenes aquí no tuvo que
ir ni llamar a un intermediario
financiero no tuvo que llevar documentos
y simplemente las transacciones las
realizó en pocos minutos nos preguntamos
si realmente esto es factible el día de
hoy y probablemente conoce explicaba
javier muy probablemente ya esas
tecnologías están corriendo en el mundo
ahora qué pasa con todas estas
tecnologías en realidad lo que estamos
viendo es que hace y como dice bq
conocida es que hacen más fácil la
experiencia del usuario para usar los
servicios financieros lo que estamos
hablando del reconocimiento del iris las
huellas digitales y también el uso del
block change que permite de una forma
descentralizada integrar información a
través de una identificación plena del
usuario facilitar las transacciones que
ejecutan con las entidades financieras y
principalmente en todo el tema de
conozca su cliente y la protección de
datos que eso significa
ahora también lo que podemos estar
encontrando es que hay nuevas soluciones
y plataformas tecnológicas con
soluciones digitales que realmente con
una forma más inteligente le pueden
probar a la información suficiente al
cliente para que pueda realizar sus
transacciones de una forma fácil
accesible y realmente mucho de esto que
lo que estamos llamando y hoy en día nos
corre que es la gente
yo voy a preguntar un poco hacia el año
2008 y podemos ver un poco de
consecuencias y porque esto es una
transformación de todo el sistema
financiero y es que a partir de toda la
burbuja inmobiliaria como nos hablaba
inicialmente gerardo lo que provocó fue
una gran desconfianza de los
consumidores en estas instituciones
financieras tradicionales algunas
empresas grandes quebraron otras
tuvieron que verse obligadas a
reinventar su negocio en este caso
también tuvimos pérdidas importantes de
trabajo inclusive de gente muy preparada
financieramente que tuvo que ir a buscar
otras oportunidades
en este escenario ahí lo que estuvimos
viendo fueron fuertes impactos y podemos
ver que en el caso concreto de entidades
tradicionales financieras
internacionales tuvieron que empezar a
utilizar los servicios digitales que hoy
en día son normales y corrientes en
nuestro mercado financiero como esto a
la mejora digital en marketing en
procesos operativos en transacciones en
línea en el manejo virtual de cuentas
pero por otro lado tenemos que entender
que hay un estallido importante de
proyectos emprendedores y que realmente
se están desarrollando en latitudes como
los eeuu europa y asia que probablemente
américa latina nos lleva a la misma
velocidad
y particularmente el caso costarricense
de estos 10 años que han transcurrido
que es lo que hemos estado viendo vemos
nuevas soluciones y aplicaciones
tecnológicas que realmente cambian la
forma de hacer los negocios estamos
hablando de la inteligencia artificial
del block change del fintech de lo que
es la computación en la nube y la
internet de las cosas
esto como ahora lo vemos realmente está
al día con nosotros y particularmente en
la industria financiera hay una
transformación significativa de todos un
modelo de negocio a base de la
tecnología en el caso particular cuando
aplicamos inteligencia de negocios y el
big data a través de la predictibilidad
y el mejor manejo de datos conjuntos
para entender el comportamiento del
consumidor vemos su daba soluciones como
es por ejemplo el robot advisor lo que
se refiere a transacciones digitales en
línea lo que se refiere también a todo
un proceso también inclusive de
identificaciones de fraudes en los
negocios y la aplicación inclusive en
tecnologías para la regulación lo que
llamamos hoy en día el break tech otras
aplicaciones en lo que se refiere a la
parte de computación distribuida es la
cadena de bloques que es una tecnología
como bien lo sabemos es una cadena una
tecnología descentralizada pero que
realmente se aplica para hacer una
reducción de los costos y principalmente
muy aplicado hoy en día en grandes
bancos centrales para lo que es los
medios de pago y lo que tradicionalmente
conocemos en las monedas digitales en la
parte de criptografía lo que estamos
viendo son el diseño de contratos
inteligentes y bio mente y uso de la
biometría en contratos inteligentes
estamos hablando de la automatización de
transacciones para que sean fácil y de
experiencia al usuario cuando realiza un
negocio desde su aplicación informática
a través por ejemplo del móvil y en la
parte de biometría en la parte de
protección de identidad y seguridad de
información como lo vimos en el caso del
uso de las huellas digitales willis y
por otro lado en la parte móvil de
acceso móvil e internet todo lo que son
billeteras digitales las aplicaciones de
web los el crowdfunding entre otros
ahora que es también lo que estamos
viendo en estas nuevas tecnologías y es
que este nuevo desarrollo de productos
lo que hacen es para los usuarios que
sean más atractivos accesibles e
inclusivos sin intermediarios a menores
costos y que realmente le permiten en
algunos casos de productos obtener
mejores retornos
ahora que queremos utilizar un poco de
qué es lo que está pasando dentro de
nuestro ámbito y digamos en américa
latina
porque aquí hay un elemento importante y
es que si bien es cierto la tecnología
perdón
digamos la tecnología está abierta para
mucha gente pero hay algo importante que
en el caso de los consumidores hispanos
conforme se desarrollan soluciones en un
mismo lenguaje eso hace que los mercados
se extiendan y por eso es que quiero
puntualizar en el desarrollo en el
desarrollo del sector en el sector
financiero de las sintex en américa
latina' un estudio reciente del 2017 del
banco interamericano de desarrollo
identifica que si bien es cierto hay
brechas entre el desarrollo de estas
nuevas soluciones
en américa latina' con respecto a eeuu
europa o asia pero si realmente hay
emprendimientos que se están
desarrollando y que ya están impactando
en algunos países latinoamericanos y en
productos o servicios en segmentos y
tecnologías que son subyacentes a nivel
mundial y eso me parece importante que
tomemos atención
particularmente identificaron en este
estudio setecientos tres emprendimientos
en la región 15 países ya están
involucrados en estas en estos
desarrollos y principalmente brasil y el
caso de méxico a la cabeza que por
cierto les comento en marzo aprobaron
una ley de fintech para poder ya darle
oportunidad a estas nuevas iniciativas
en el caso de costa rica se
identificaron cinco tipos de actividades
en los cuales están el descuento de
facturas y financiamiento directo pero
realmente en mucha pequeña muy pequeña
escala
voy a mencionar algunas de los que
podrían ser emprendimientos que son
aplicados al mercado valores dentro de
este e identificado dentro de este
estudio uno de ellos es las plataformas
de financiamiento alternativo o lo que
llamamos crowdfunding eso realmente hace
que la industria tradicional de la
intermediación financiera cambie y
tenemos que ponerle atención la gestión
de finanzas personales a través de
medios y plataformas digitales para la
captación de ahorros de fácil acceso
para para el usuario
finanzas empresariales orientadas a
facturación electrónica y contabilidad
digital lo cual también eso hace un
ahorro en costos del modelo tradicional
de operación con una gestión patrimonial
en fondos mutuos de manera remota de tal
manera de que con estas plataformas y
con algoritmos inteligentes le dan
soluciones de inversión a las personas
oa los consumidores financieros también
plataformas de negociación de activos
financieros lo que llamamos a través
y negociación en valores con trading y
en el mercado valores para todo lo que
es compra y venta de los activos
financieros a través de plataformas con
tecnología basada en cadena de bloques y
también tenemos empresas que bien
conocidas por algunos de aquí que están
en metido sentido en servicios de
tecnología y visualmente dándoles
soluciones a las entidades financieras
en temas de manejo de información
biométrica autorización de transacciones
en fin un desarrollo interesante lo que
vemos realmente es que hay una buena
noticia o sea realmente ya están casi a
las puertas de nuestras casas o
podríamos las puertas de nuestros
mercados pero realmente lo que vemos
aquí es que hay una gran oportunidad
porque esto va a promover la inclusión
financiera que es un tema que se discute
seriamente dentro de nuestros mercados
ahora
todo esto está sucediendo y la pregunta
es dónde están los reguladores y qué
están haciendo la regulación sobre esto
y aquí hay un elemento importante que
nosotros tenemos que considerar y es que
nosotros debemos como reguladores apoyar
y realmente
facilitar el proceso de acceso de estas
nuevas soluciones financieras realmente
nos corresponde aplicar regulaciones
inteligentes o sea hay que reconocer los
beneficios que tiene la innovación
financiera y estamos llamados a entender
este funcionamiento y apoyarnos y
promover su consolidación esto realmente
es un tema que no es fácil esto hay que
es un proceso de discusión y hay que
tomarse el tiempo con la industria que
lo está desarrollando pero aparte de eso
hay algo importante que si quiero
decirles es que la regulación no es mala
una profesora de la universidad de
cambridge que es nicole de ryan y ella
dice que la regulación es importante
para las economías y enfoca en tres
direcciones una dice amplia mercados y
por consiguiente consumidores o
participantes por otro lado dice genera
la competencia esto porque por un lado
en el caso de la creación de mercados y
ampliación de participantes es porque
debe dar la oportunidad a pequeños y
grandes empresarios para que con reglas
comunes puedan actuar en nuestros
mercados esto hace una ampliación de la
base de la economía por otro lado la
generación de competencia eso lo que
hace es que la regulación debe promover
una sana competencia entre todos lo que
llamamos buenas conductas de mercado y
eso eso es importante en materia de
regulación el otro aspecto que con base
en los dos puntos anteriores nos da que
con esto tenemos consumido buscamos
consumidores protegidos que realmente es
al final de la cadena lo que busca
ahora
veamos un poco que es y en qué camino
van estos reguladores les pongo el caso
concreto de la bolsa de valores
canadiense que recientemente en enero
pasado acaba de anunciar la
implementación del sistema de
compensación y liquidación a través de
cadena de bloques para facilitar la
negociación de deuda y la negociación de
acciones de lo que se ha llamaríamos
tokens o activos virtuales lo cual hoy
en día sólo vemos muy relacionados con
cripto monedas pero realmente la cripto
moneda de la base como digamos sintética
para generar el producto
por otro lado les comento hay otras
iniciativas en américa latina' que se
han ya se están formalizando como les
dije en el caso de méxico ya tiene más
de 238 empresas de fintech de las cuales
están en muchas de ellas ya en procesos
de autorización y funcionando y muchos
principalmente en el mercado de valores
en todo lo que es asesoría digitalizada
y también la transacción de operaciones
financieras a través de medios digitales
para su aprobación a parte digamos de
otros emprendimientos que conocemos que
no están tan vinculados como por ejemplo
todo lo que se refiere al scoring de
crédito que es casi un servicio que se
le da a las entidades financieras
ahora que lo que nos corresponde y nos
corresponde realmente tomar manos en
acción en esto sea si hay algo claro es
que están ahí y ya hay que ponerles
atención o sea los reguladores no
podemos hacernos de lado y tenemos que
tomar una posición proactiva para eso yo
identificaría algunos elementos claves
que nos parece uno es que debemos
nosotros aprender de estos modelos de
negocio o sea el regulador debe aprender
del modelo de negocio e identificar cuál
es ese marco regulatorio que sea importe
sea inteligente de aplicar algunos de
los casos por ejemplo se han utilizado
modelos unbox o que se llama cajas de
arena que son formas de prueba pero
realmente son marcos regulatorios
controlados que permiten que estas
innovaciones se acerquen al regulador
empiezan a funcionar y a partir de ahí
se generan nuevos emprendimientos y
nuevas empresas ya formalizadas en el
mercado
otro aspecto que es importante es que
las entidades que los innovadores deben
de aprender cuál debe ser las mejores
prácticas para crear su negocio o sea un
buen gobierno corporativo como hablaba
hace un rato
generando de un gobierno corporativo
gestión de riesgos transparencia e
integridad de los procesos operativos
que no podemos dejar de lado por otro
lado se requiere también que los
consumidores estén debidamente
informados eso significa que el
proveedor del servicio debe dar
información accesible que debe ser
digamos lo ajustado al tipo de
inversionista a través de la aplicación
de la inteligencia de datos y así de esa
manera poder operar sanamente en el
mercado de que tenga sostenibilidad
finalmente hay dos aspectos uno son los
acuerdos jurisdiccionales entre países
sabemos que la innovación financiera no
tiene fronteras por consiguiente se
requiere que los diferentes reguladores
de las diferentes jurisdicciones
tengamos el entendimiento suficiente
para apoyar la innovación de tal manera
que si en un país ya están avanzados en
aprobaciones para ciertas entidades los
países nuestros podamos o en el caso
costarricense ya poder facilitar ese
proceso de innovación
y finalmente y algo que también lo toco
gerardo es el tema de la educación
financiera que no se puede quedar de
lado o sea debemos facilitar el
conocimiento necesario que permita a los
consumidores financieros y a los
participantes a realmente hacer
productos de una forma inteligente e
informada
ahora como dije son manos en acción y mi
conclusión es que la innovación
financiera basada en tecnología
realmente nos compete a todos los que
estamos aquí sentados
debemos aprovechar los beneficios que da
para el consumidor financiero y también
para las empresas y por consiguiente a
todo el mercado lo que significa con
esto es que si tenemos que tomar manos
en acción significa acercarnos a los
innovadores a tener una discusión
abierta y realmente promover esta
industria con la debida fortaleza que se
requiere para que el mercado sea
sostenible en el tiempo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]